ich bin ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
fassungslos alle zahlen zeigen dass bis
zu 90 prozent aller krone toten aus
pflegeheimen kommen und in den
ausführungen von herrn lothar wieler hat
das nicht einmal ein prozent der
redezeit bekommen
er hat immer nur darüber gesprochen dass
die menschen zu hause bleiben sollen
dass die menschen nicht verreisen sollen
dass die menschen immer noch zu häufig
miteinander essen
aber er hat nicht darüber gesprochen wie
man pflegeheime zu schützen kann jetzt
in der letzten antwort als er darauf
angesprochen wurde hat er wieder nur
gesagt es geht darum die inzidenz
insgesamt niedrig zu halten und dann ist
es möglich auch pflegeheime zu schützen
aber an welche realität orientiert er
sich denn die maßnahmen zeigen doch
allesamt es ist nicht möglich die
instanz zu drücken und zu halten klar
wir können in einem kompletten locker
umgehen und dann kriegen wir auch die
altenheime mit geschützt das machen wir
aus guten gründen nicht und dann hat man
sich eben an der realität zu orientieren
so lange die zahlen hoch sind und das
werden sie im winter offen bleiben das
sind sie überall in europa braucht es
zusätzliche schutzmaßnahmen für die
pflegeheime und ich verstehe das nicht
dass in der ersten pressekonferenz mitte
januar
nachdem wir den tödlichsten dezember
seit vielen jahren hinter uns haben
herr bieler sich hinsetzt und erstmal
sich weigert darüber zu sprechen wo die
menschen den sterben wir haben sämtliche
bundesländer abgefragt in nrw waren das
55 prozent aller corona toten kommen aus
pflegeheimen schleswig holstein waren
das 89 prozent ich meine wir haben eine
gruppe von menschen die stirbt an diesem
virus und zwar mehr als alle anderen und
dann sitzt da der chef von deutschlands
oberster solchen behörde und will
einfach nicht darüber sprechen sondern
wiederholt plattitüden die wir alle seit
einem jahr schon gut kennen
hinter jeder zahl ist auch ein mensch ja
das ist uns jetzt allen bewusst und weil
wir so wenig testen gibt es noch viel
mehr infizierte menschen die wir
überhaupt nicht kennen und wir testen
übrigens nicht erst seit weihnachten
wenig sondern wir testen schon seit
vielen monaten deutlich weniger als
viele andere länder in europa und die
frage des reporters was ist denn mit den
viel gerühmten deutschen test
kapazitäten nix ist damit er hat da ist
wirklich gar nichts damit wenn man sich
die zahlen im september im oktober im
november anschaut das ist nicht kurz vor
weihnachten daher deutschland auch schon
wahnsinnig wenig getestet
es ist deutschland nicht gelungen
die test kapazitäten hochzufahren ist
ist deutschland nicht gelungen die
pflegeheime zu schützen und ihr haben
wir ein lkw chef lothar wieler erlebt
der weiter einfach mit versucht die
menschen mit plattitüden daran zu
erinnern dass man sich an die maßnahmen
halten soll und die menschen fragen sich
vermutlich ja wie lange denn noch hat er
hat gesagt ja wenige monate oder viele
monate
aber egal ob bis ende des jahres werden
wir es schon geschafft haben also wenn
das eine strategie ist und weiß ich auch
nicht mehr
er hat auch gesagt er ist glücklich
impfen sei ein privileg wird das dann da
irgendwie beschädigt die ganze im
strategie weil wir merken ja alle das
ist einfach zu lange dauerte wurde
massenhaft beschönigt sagen was man so
also wie schockiert aber weisen
tatsächlich die forderung geht nicht
mehr essen
also man hat wirklich das gefühl oder
wieder er hat auch relativ klar
angedeutet dass man die maßnahmen nicht
ausreichen die wir gerade haben aber
ganz ehrlich sein kollege der physiker
dr braucht man hat ja gesagt dass eben
genau sehen dass die maßnahmen nicht so
wirken wie das erste mal weil die leute
wahrscheinlich nicht so wahnsinnig gut
daran halten vielleicht auch einfach
keine lust mehr haben und jetzt wieder
den chef der obersten deutschen
beförderung das mal aufzugreifen
der sagt das reicht mir alles noch nicht
und wie kann es sein dass ihr mittags
zusammen ist das ist schon schockierend
die impfungen ja auch da wurde wurde
viel viel schönen geräte finde ich auch
was mich auch schockiert er hat der zu
mut machen weil sie zieht er sich da
auch gerne sachen dran er hat gesagt die
fallzahlen stabilisieren sich und der
anstieg ist nicht mehr so steil jetzt
durch mal geguckt also heute die 25.000
obama gesprochen
gestern waren 19.600 mal infizierte
vorgestern 12.000 das sieht jetzt den
laien wien an stieg aus und schon gar
nicht wegen der stabilität und er hat es
ja auch gesagt werden ich vorher auch
besprochen die zeit stimmt ja nicht
also worauf war das jetzt das ist leider
etwas was ich daran gezogen hat um den
leuten weiter mut zu machen was ja
richtig ist natürlich so auch den leuten
mut machen aber ob das jetzt unbedingt
die variante ist weiß ich nicht wir sind
bild und wir liefern dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren